You've come out with an album?
I have, I have.
Well the Muppets and
I went into the studio
to do this album, we sort of got lost.
Ended up singing with a lot of people
and it made a nice album,
so we put it all together, lot's of fun.
Yeah, well I was gonna ask you about this.
(audience laughs)
This is very risky,
very risky when actors,
when actors try and sing.
You know, Telly Savalas tried it.
What, you're kidding.
Yeah, William Shatner.
(audience laughs)
Wow.
William Shatner tried it.
A lot of people, Leonard Nimoy,
I think all of the Star
Trek cast has tried it.
Gee.
Yeah, it's very risky.
Yeah, well it can be risky, sure.
But I've actually been singing for years.
I'm kind of known as a
singer, as well as, and actor.
It's kind of a frog thing.
Go to the swamp sometime.
You'll hear us singing.
I didn't realize that about you.
You're so talented.
Well, that's very nice of you.
Yeah, nothing really.
Nothing really.
Now, I understand (audience laughs)
in part of this you're,
and part of some, you're actually singing
with Ozzy Osbourne?
Well actually, yes that's true.
That's true.
Ozzy was around.
Miss Piggy actually sung with Ozzy.
Miss Piggy--
Oh, Miss Piggy does.
Yeah, it's very interesting.
Ozzy has a way with barnyard animals.
(audience loudly laughs)
Yeah, I don't know.
It's true.
(audience claps)
Who knew, who knew?
That's true.
Now, I worked on the,
I worked on the,
I was asked to be in the video.
I guess you got a lot
of people in the video.
We did.
We got a whole long list
of big celebrities, yeah.
Yes, thank you.
And you were great by the way.
Oh, thank you very much.
A little thing I do.
But I was curious about this.
I was back stage there and I sensed
that there was a lot
of tension back stage.
Oh, oh you mean like
lots of egos and stuff.
Yeah.
It seemed like a lot of
you guys were very tense
and you sort of, success
has gone to your head.
Yeah, it happens sometimes.
But a lot of that was Miss Piggy.
We told people to just check
their egos at the door,
but we couldn't find a check
room large enough for Piggy.
(audience laughs)
She can instigate a lot of
problems with big stars.
Now, speaking of her, are
you still an item with her?
Are you guys still going out?
An item?
Yeah, are you still going
out with Miss Piggy?
No, no Conan, I believe
you have been misinformed.
You see, may I take this
opportunity on national television
to say folks, that there is nothing,
nothing going on between Piggy and I
other than a purely
professional relationship.
Ah.
No, no, please.
Really, really?
A lot of us were misled.
Well, I think that has
a lot do with Miss Piggy
being able to fax her
press releases directly
to the "National Enquirer."
(audience laughs)
I see.
Now, let me ask you something.
Who is she involved with?
Is she seeing anybody right now?
Well there is, and this
is only a rumor, mind you,
but I hear that she has
been seen around town
with Tom Arnold.
(audience loudly laughs)
Yeah.
You heard it here, folks.
Yeah, but who am I to mind, you know?
I would not mind.
I would not mind at all.
She can do whatever she likes.
It's okay with me.
I don't care.
It's okay.
She's a pig, what can I say?
(Conan and audience laughs)
I'll let you (laughs).
Oh, it's the 90's now.
Women can do whatever they want.
Sure, and they can even be pigs.
Yes.
Nothing personal.
I don't wanna get letters.
No, you're not gonna
get no letters at all.
No letters at all.
Kermit, let me ask you.
I know that you did,
you substituted for Johnny Carson once.
That's true.
And you actually sat in
for, was it Larry King?
I did do that one time, yes.
Not so long ago?
I was great fun.
Yeah, well you've actually,
so then you've had quite a bit experience
with this talk show thing.
Have you ever, ever considered
doing your own talk show?
Well, I suppose
if the opportunity
presented itself, maybe.
I've been told that I look sort of
like a short green Regis Philbin.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, yeah?
But I don't know.
I can see it, I can see it.
Yeah, maybe, maybe.
It was fun doing the Larry King thing.
It's kinda scary though.
You know, it goes, I mean
you do this every night
but I'm just kind of a simple frog.
You know, I just--
No, but you seem to do it well.
You're a very good conversationalist.
Well, I don't know--
C'mon, you are.
Well okay, all right, maybe I am.
Maybe I should give it a try sometime.
What do you think, huh?
(audience claps)
Everyone has a show now.
You should have a show.
Well, thank you.
I'd love to give it a try, sure, sure.
Anybody out there listening
that has any shows around?
Just--
There are plenty.
There are plenty, just
walk around New York
for like 20 minutes.
I've heard that, yes.
Yeah, all right.
Now, I know that you're
up on current events.
Is there anything you wanna talk about?
Any current events at all,
that you know you, as a frog
would like to comment on?
Well, you know I try to
be up on current events,
but I've had a little problem recently
because I live in the swamp,
and it's very hard to
have a television there.
It's kind of an electrical
and water thing,
so the cable's been out.
You may be able to fill
me in on a few things.
I don't know.
No, I couldn't tell you a thing.
I don't watch TV.
You don't?
It's a waste of valuable time.
Well, okay, let's, yeah, yeah.
I'll go along with that one.
All right, so buy yeah,
you're enjoying yourself.
Everything's fine and you've
had a good time and the album.
Is there anything else you
want to say about the album?
Well, it was a lot of fun.
It's coming out in a week or so
and it's got all the Muppets
and we sing with people like,
as you said, Ozzy Osbourne,
one of my old favorite,
I don't mean old, I didn't
mean that, cut that part.
One of my best friends, Linda Ronstadt.
Oh, very good.
Yes, I love Linda Ronstadt.
She's one of my favorite people,
and all those kind of folks,
you know good singers, good songs.
Excellent, well listen,
I wanna wish you the best
of luck with the album.
Oh, thank you.
I will ask you, next
time you are on the show,
would you sit in the chair?
Ah, I'll see what I can do.
You and Bobcat Goldthwait are the only two
that have sat up there.
Oh really?
Oh, at least I'm in good company.
Yeah, you're in very good company.
(audience and Conan laugh)
It's a frog thing.
We have to, you know,
you said you look down
on some of your guests?
Well, I just wanted to be up
here at eye level, you know.
Ah, very nice.
Well listen, Kermit, thank
you very much for stopping by.
Well, it's been a pleasure.
Best of luck with the album,
Kermit the Frog everybody!
(audience cheers)
[Conan] Give him a hand!